[موسيقى]
30 عاما من ايديكس 30 عاما استطاع خلالها
المعرض ان يثبت نفسه كواحد من اهم المعارض
الدفاعيه على مستوى العالم كما بات فرصه
لصناع القرار وكذلك للقاده الميدانيين ان
يتعرفوا على احدث المنظومات البريه
والبحريه والجويه التي تعرضها الشركات
الدفاعيه على مستوى العالم اهلا بكم في
عسكري تاليا وتغطيه خاصه لايديكس 2023 من
العاصمه الاماراتيه ابو ظبي
[موسيقى]
الاماراتيه تكشف عن احدى عشره مسيره جديده
خلال معرض ايدكس 2023 مسيرات متنوعه ما
بين مسيرات بريه وكذلك مسيارات بحريه
وايضا مسيرات جويه الجديد ان المسيرات
الجديده بالكامل هي مسيرات متعدده المهام
تستطيع القيام بمهام الرز والاستطلاع او
كذلك القيام بمهام قتاليه
شركه سرب السعوديه لانظمه الطيران توقع
اتفاقا مع شركه
الامريكيه والتي تعد احدى شركات ريسيون
الشهيره هذا الاتفاق يضمن التعاون
والتطوير المشترك لمسيره ابقيق فيما يخص
انظمه التحكم والقياده والسيطره ابقيق هي
مسيره تم تصنيعها بالكامل داخل السعوديه
بحقوق ملكيه فكريه كامله وهي طائره متعدده
المهام سواء للرصد او للاستطلاع او كذلك
للاستهداف الدقيق كما ان لديها القدره على
التصدي للطائرات بدون طيار او الزوارق
المفخخه
منذ بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا غابت الشركات
الدفاعيه الروسيه عن كل المعارض في اوروبا
غابت روسيا عن اوروبا لكنها حضرت في الشرق
الاوسط حضرت في ايدكس هذا العام عبر
مجموعه من المجسمات مجسمات لصواريخ موجهه
وكذلك ذخائر مدفئ ضد المدفعيه وايضا ذخائر
لمدافع وكذلك مجسمات لاحدث ما في الترسانه
العسكريه الروسيه من اسلحه طبقا لخبراء
فان موسكو تسعى مؤخرا الى تعزيز شركتها
الاستراتيجيه مع دول منطقه الشرق الاوسط
بل انها باتت اكثر انفتاحا على التعاون
العسكري مع دول المنطقه ولانها ايضا اصبحت
موافقه على نقل التكنولوجيا ونقل الافكار
في مجال الصناعات الدفاعيه للدول التي
تسعى لتعزيز صناعاتها في هذا المجال
الاتفاقات الابراهيميه كما فتحت الباب
للمزيد من التعاون والتنسيق السياسي
والامني مع الدول التي وقعت هذه
الاتفاقيات مع اسرائيل فتحت كذلك الباب
امام الشركات الاسرائيليه العامله في مجال
الصناعات الدفاعيه لتعزيز وجودها في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط من بينها شركه رافائيل
الاسرائيليه التي حتى سبقت معرضي ايدكس
بفتح مكتب لها هنا في العاصمه الاماراتيه
ابو ظبي حول هذا الموضوع وكذلك حول مشاركه
شركه رافائيل في المعرض معنا الجنرال
يعافر الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه رافائيل
الاسرائيليه اولا مصر يعاب جنرال يعاب
اهلا بك معنا مجددا في عسكريتانيا دعنا
نبدا بالحديث عن المكتب الذي افتتحتموه في
العاصمه الاماراتيه ابوظبي ما الذي تسعون
اليه من خلال هذا المكتب وهل تطمحون بان
يكون هذا المكتب مختصر فقط على وجودكم في
دوله الامارات ام انه لديكم طموح بان يكون
مكتب اقليمي لكم في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
بشكل كامل
ابو ظبي افتتحنا مكتبنا في ابو ظبي منذ
فتره قصيره كجزء من استراتيجيتنا وفهمنا
للاتفاق الابراهيمي هو ليس مجرد شعار بل
سيتحقق بالفعل هذه خطوه كبيره من وجهه
نظرنا لتاسيس وجود المستمر هنا في ابوظبي
وعلى امل ان تكون هذه هي الخطوه الاولى
لفتح المزيد من المكاتب حول المنطقه اعتقد
ان هذه الخطوه منطقيه ضمن شراكتنا
الاستراتيجيه في المنطقه
مصر نعلم جيدا بان شركه رفاهيه لابد لها
من موافقه مسبقه من وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه حتى تقوم بتصدير اي من
منتجاتها لكن فيما يتعلق بمنطقه الشرق
الاوسط يعني ما هي المنظومات التي من
الممكن ان نراها في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
على سبيل المثال
وتستطيعون الحصول بالموافقه عليها من
وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيلي
بعض منتجاتنا بعد ان حصلنا على الموافقه
لعرض جميع انظمتنا هنا خلال عمليه تعتمد
على العمل الذي نقوم به الا ان هدفنا
الختامي هو جزء من الاستراتيجيه القوميه
وسياسه وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه وهي جلب
احدث انظمه رافائيل واكثرها تقدما الى
جانب منتجات اخرى من الصناعه الدفاعيه
الاسرائيليه الى شركائنا في جميع انحاء
العالم خاصه في هذه المنطقه كجزء من
استراتيجيه توسيع الشراكه الاستراتيجيه
جنرال الكثير من الدول الان باتت ترى بانه
الصواريخ الباليسيه هي التي تشكل التهديد
الاكبر على مستوى العالم وانتم لديكم في
شركه رافائيل طورتم منظومه سبايدر وهي
خلفي هذه المنظومه المضاده للصواريخ
الباليسيه اولا ما الذي تتميز به هذه
المنظومه والى اي مدى هذه المنظومه
اثبتت نجاح في تجاربها على التصدي
للصواريخ البالست
سبقوا ان استخدمت منظومه سبايدر من قبل
العديد من الدول من ضمنها دول الناتو
واثبتت جدارتها القتاليه وتستخدم احدث
الصواريخ في السابق كانت منظومه تصدي جو
جو وتطورت لتصبح منظومه دفاع جوي ونحن في
طور توسيع قدراتها بدانا مع منظومه سبايدر
للمدى القصير ثم تطورت لتصل الى المدى
المتوسط ثم البعيد والان نعمل على دمجها
جميعا في منظومه سبايدر متكامله لتشمل
الرادار والقياده والسيطره وصواريخ سبايدر
ونحن الان نبحث في المرحله التاليه التي
تشمل كيفيه التعامل مع عده تهديدات مثل
تلك التي شاهدناها في اوكرانيا والتي بدات
تنتشر في كل انحاء العالم واقصد على وجه
الخصوص الصواريخ الباليستيه والامر الفريد
الذي يميز هذا النظام هو القدره على توسيع
قدراته طوال الوقت باستخدام نفس النظام
وتحسينه وهذا جزء من مفهوم توسيع القدرات
والتكيف مع التطور المستمر للتهديدات
يعني لديكم منظومه وهي هذه المنظومه التي
وصفها حتى رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بانها ستغير شكل اللعبه في الاقليم هذه
المنظومه المتخصصه في التصدي للطائرات
المسيره بشكل كبير
وذات تكلفه اقل حتى من منظومه القبه
الحديديه اين وصل العمل على هذه المنظومه
وهل بالفعل ستقومون على تنفيذ هذه
المنظومه التي تتحدثون عن انها ستخفض من
تكلفه التصدي لطائرات المسيره حتى 4
دولارات فقط
في تفاصيل الارقام ولكن الخطوه المستقبليه
التاليه ستشمل دمج منظومه السلاح الليزر
بالطاقه العاليه مع نظام اعتراض في اي
منظومه دفاع جوي حيث ستكون لدينا حلول
حركيه ولا حركيه تعتمد على الليزر
والصواريخ وبلا شك فعندما ننظر الى
المنظومه باكملها فستنخفض التكلفه لاننا
نستطيع استخدام الليزر عده مرات في نفس
جهاز الاطلاق وهذا جزء من رؤيتنا لاستخدام
التكنولوجيا المتقدمه باستخدام نظام
الليزر كنظام مكمل للنظام الحركي
وبالتاكيد نستطيع التحدث عن معدل التكلفه
لنظام اعتراض ولكن علينا الاخذ بعين
الاعتبار النظام باكمله لكي ندرك ان
الليزر سيكون عاملا استراتيجيا لتغيير
قواعد اللعبه في الحروب ونحن فخورون لاننا
بدانا بتطويره ونعتقد انه سيكون من بين
اكثر الانظمه تقدما وسريعا جدا في
العمليات
وانت رجل عسكري السابق الان ونحن نتحدث عن
اكثر من عام من الحرب في اوكرانيا التجربه
الميدانيه اثبتت اهميه منظومات الدفاع
النشط ولديكم منظومه تعتمد عليها حتى
الكثير من الدول الاوروبيه في الدباباتها
يعني بعد هذه التجربه ما الذي استفدتم به
من خلال المتابعه الميدانيه لما يحدث على
الارض وهل وجدتم بانه هناك حاجه لتطوير
منظومه التي تقدمونها في الشركه
عندما ننظر الى الدروس المستفاده من
اوكرانيا فهناك العديد منها مثل اهميه
الصواريخ بعيده المدى مثل المضاده
للدبابات التي اثبتت فائدتها الكبيره
لمهاجمه الدبابات والدرس الاخر هو كيفيه
حمايه انظمتنا عندما ننقل المنصات
والدبابات والمركبات القتاليه ونظام تروفي
الشهير وهو الوحيد الذي اثبت جدارته في
المعارك هو من الامكانات الفريده ونسعى
لنشر نظام تروفي وتطبيقه في جميع انحاء
العالم وهذا بالتاكيد يعتمد على الدوله
التي سنتعامل معها وسياسه التصدير الخاصه
بوزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه نحن فخورون جدا
بتقديم هذا الحلق قبل نحو 11 عاما وكما
قلت فقد اثبت جدارته في المعارك في نفس
الوقت الذي نسعى فيه لتطوير القادم الا ان
اهميه نظام الحمايه النشطي اثبت اهميته
لكل من يرغب باستخدام مركبه قتاليه على
ارض المعركه
جنرال انت تعلم بانه ايران تحاول بشكل
كبير التطوير برنامجها للصواريخ الباليسيه
والان حتى تحاول الحصول على تكنولوجيا
متعلقه بالصواريخ الفرد صوتيه الا يشكل
هذا الامر تحديدا لبرنامج الدفاع الصاروخي
المتعلق باسرائيل هذا من جانب ومن جانب
الاخر يعني الا يضع منظومه القبه الحديديه
امام اختبار اخر ربما لم تختبره في السر
عندما ننظر الى المنطقه وحتى بقيه انحاء
العالم سندرك ان الجميع يحاول ان ينتج
صواريخ اسرعه اكثر فاعليه لتحديث منظومات
الدفاع الجوي والجميع يتحدث الان عن
الصواريخ فرط الصوتيه التي لن تكون حكرا
على روسيا فقط بل ستنتشر في كل المنطقه
غير ان مهمتنا في رفائيل هي جزء من
الاستراتيجيه القوميه الاسرائيليه هي
تطوير انظمتنا لمواجهه التحديات الحاليه
وكذلك المستقبليه وعندما ننظر الى
التحديات المستقبليه فنحن ندرك ان صواريخ
ستكون اسرع بكثير مثل فرط الصوتيه ولكن
هذا جزء من مهمتنا ونحن نبحث عن الحلول
وبالتاكيد لا استطيع ان اتحدث عنها
بالتفصيل ولكننا ندرك ان هذا التهديد قادم
ولدينا الحل لمواجهته
هذه هي الدبابه التي المح الرئيس الفرنسيه
منويل ماكرو بامكانيه ارسالها قريبا الى
الاوكرانيين دبابه لوكليرك هذه الدبابه هي
دبابه قتال رئيسى من الجيل الثالث تصنعها
شركه نكسر الفرنسيه دخلت هذه الدبابه
الخدمه في عام
1992 كما انها خضعت لعدد من عمليات
التطوير مع جعلها واحده من اقوى الدبابات
داخل حلف تمتلك لوكليرك منظومه لتوجيه
النيران عبر الليزر كما انها تمتلك ايضا
منظومه رؤيه ليليه حراريه كما انها ايضا
مسلحه بمدفع من عيار 120 مليمترا يمكن
تلقيمه بشكل اوتوماتيكي باثنتين وعشرين
قذيفه متنوعه تصل سرعه دبابه لوكليرك الى
71 كيلو مترا في الساعه اما طولها فيقارب
العشره امتار اما ارتفاعها فاكثر من
المترين ونصف هذا يجعلها واحده من دبابات
القتال الرئيسيه صغيره بينما يتكون طاقمها
من ثلاثه افراد تخدم لوكليرك في فرنسا
وكذلك في دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده
بالاضافه الى الاردن
[موسيقى]
تحقيق السيطره الميدانيه على الارض هي
واحده من اهم المهمات التي يحرص عليها
القاده دائما في المعارك وبالتالي تاتي
اهميه سلاح المدرعات ذلك تاتي اهميه
العربات المصفحه وكذلك ناقلات
الفرنسيه هي واحده من اقدم الشركات
الاوروبيه العامله في هذا المجال على مدى
سنوات ولديها الكثير من المنتجات التي
تخدم بالفعل سلاح المدرعات داخل عدد من
الجيوش حول العالم للحديث اكثر عن احدث
منتجات هذه الشركه وكذلك مشاركتها في معرض
ايدكس 2023 هنا في العاصمه الاماراتيه
ابوظبي معنا السيد ايمنويل رئيس شركه اكوس
الفرنسيه اولا مصر اهلا بك معنا في
عسكريتانيا يعني بدايه ما هي ابرز
المنتجات التي تقدمها شركه اركوس الفرنسيه
هنا في ابوظبي في
اشكرك لدعوتي وانا سعيد جدا لوجود هنا
معكم نعم معرض ايدكس مهم جدا بالنسبه لنا
ونعرض فيه احدث منتجاتنا والخدمات التي
توفرها
وكما ترى من خلفي فنحن نعرض اليوم
وهي مركبه ذات درجه عاليه من الحمايه لنقل
الجنود وهي مجهزه باحدث محطات الاسلحه
عاليه التكنولوجيا التي يمكن التحكم فيها
عن بعد وهي معده ايضا بصواريخ مضاده
للدبابات مزوده من قبل شركه فرنسيه اخرى
هي ام بي دي اي كما نحاول في هذا المعرض
استعراض تشكيله متنوعه من منتجاتنا التي
يمكن ان نوفرها لعملائنا في المنطقه
والعالم
مصر الجيش الفرنسي كان بالفعل قام بارسال
عدد من منتجات اركوس الى الاوكرانيين ومن
بينها المدرعات كيف تابعتم على مدار عام
واكثر من هذه من المعارك البريه على الارض
اداء هذه المدرعات على الارض واداء هذه
المنتجات ميدانيا على الارض وهل انعكس هذا
على خططكم في عمليات الانتاج
الوقت مبكرا لاستغلال جميع الدروس من
النزاع ولكن بالفعل فان فرنسا والجيش
الفرنسي زود القوات الاوكرانيه بمنظومات
مختلفه مثل المدفعيه الدقيقه بعيده المدى
المتمثله بمدفع سيزار الذي ساهمت اركوس
بتزويده بقدرات التنقل وكذلك انواع مختلفه
من المركبات المدرعه لاغراض نقل الجنود او
للاغراض اللوجستيه بلا شك هذا النزاع فيه
الكثير من الدروس التي يمكن ان نستفيد
منها مثل حمايه الافراد بشكل افضل
والتموقع الافضل لاطلاق المدفعيه بعيده
المدى وكذلك التنقل والعمليات اللجوسيه
التي هي عملون الاساسي وكيفيه ضمان
الاعمال اللوجستيه المناسبه لايصال
المعدات والذخيره للقوات هناك الكثير الذي
يمكن ان نتعلمه وما زلنا نتعلم والقصه
للاسف لم تنتهي بعد
مصر يعني قطاع تصنيع العربات المصفحه يشهد
كبيره وهناك الكثير من الشركات التي لديها
منتجات حول العالم في هذا القطاع تحديدا
لكن ما هو الشيء الذي تعتقدون انه يميز
منتجات اركوس في هذا القطاع تحديدا له
بالفعل هناك الكثير من المنافسه ونحن
نحترمها ولكننا متميزون بثلاثه امور اولا
منتجاتنا كلها اثبتت جدارتها فنحن نجهز
القوات المسلحه الفرنسيه منذ عده عقود
ومنتجاتنا تستخدم في انواع مختلفه من
العمليات فنحن متميزون في توفير الحلول
القويه والمعتمده والامر الثاني نحن
متميزون بخدماتنا لان الامر لا يتعلق فقط
بتوفير المنتجات بل كذلك استدامتها طوال
مده استخدامها ونحن قريبون جدا من عملائنا
ونوفر لهم تلك الخدمات وثالثا نحن منفتحون
لتوطين منتجاتنا مع شركائنا من اجل
صناعتها محليا فبهذه المميزات الثلاث
نتميز على منافسين الاساسيين
الان هناك زياده في الانفاق العسكري على
مستوى العالم وتحديدا في اوروبا حتى بعض
الدول الاوروبيه الان لا
ول يعني ميزانيه دفاعيه باحجام كبيره داخل
عدد من هذه الدول في اوروبا لكن كيف
تتعاملون مع هذا الامر هل لديكم الامكانيه
الانتاجيه لكل هذه الطلبات لانه نعلم بان
هذا اثر على انه بات الان لديكم الكثير من
الطلبات والتعاقدات كيف تتعاملون مع هذا
الامر
هذا سؤال مهم وانت محق فقد شهدنا خلال
الاشهر الماضيه زياده في الطلب على
منتجاتنا ولا تزال لدينا القدره على زياده
الانتاج وبالمناسبه هذه الجهود هي من ضمن
متطلبات الصناعه الفرنسيه وهي القدره على
زياده الانتاج من اجل تلبيه الطلب
المتزايد وفيما يخص شركه اركوس لا يزال
لدينا ما يكفي من القدرات السلبيه الطلبات
المتزايده
على مدى سنوات كانت متواجده في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط ولديها بالفعل شراكه مع عدد
من جيوش هذه المنطقه كيف تقيمون هذه
وكذلك الى اي مدى هناك تعاون ما بين اركوس
والشركات العامله في الصناعات الدفاعيه
الان في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
في المنطقه فنحن نتشارك مع الصناعه
المحليه على سبيل المثال لتقديم الخدمات
وتحديث منتجاتنا في تلك الدوله وهذه
الطريقه جيده لاستغلال القيمه الكامله
للمنتجات اما عندما نتعامل مع منتجات
جديده فنحاول كما ذكرت ان نؤسس شراكات
محليه لشراء المنتجات محليا او لتجميعها
لكي تسهم صناعه محليه بنسبه عاليه وهذا ما
لدينا في دول مختلفه من المنطقه ونرغب
بزياده هذا التعاون فمثلا نستطيع احيانا
ان نقوم بتزويد القاعده المتدحرجه وبامكان
الدوله ان تصمم وتصنع بنفسها هيكل المركبه
او المعدات او تكامل الانظمه ونحن مرنون
جدا في هذا السياق
[موسيقى]
بعد النجاح والضجه الاعلاميه الكبيره التي
حققتها مسيرات بيركتار التركيه والتي
تقدمها شركه بايكار مسيره جديده تقدمها
شركه تركيش ايروس هذه المسيره التي تسمى
تعد احدث واكبر المسيرات التي تقدمها شركه
ودخلت بالفعل الى الخدمه في عام 2021
مسيره تكتيكيه تستطيع القيام بمهام الرصد
والاستطلاع وكذلك مهام هجوميه عبر صواريخ
موجهه بالليزر وكذلك قنابل ذكيه هذه
المسيره تستطيع التحليق لمده تصل الى خمس
وخمسين ساعه هناك ست مسيرات بالفعل من هذه
المسيره تخدم لدى الجيش التركي استخدمها
مؤخرا في تغطيه شبكات الاتصال فوق المناطق
المنكوبه بسبب الجر الزلزال الذي ضرب
مناطق في جنوب تركيا
[موسيقى]